do you guys uh
so the next thing i know that's supposed
to get legalized i know in san francisco
mushrooms are legalized
and i know that like the idea of micro
dosing mushrooms
has become more of like a um
an accepted thing amongst like yeah they
tell them
it's like it's
like invested in a big mushroom company
uh
do you guys dabble in the mushroom game
at all the psychedelics
i don't personally i actually ain't
never
dabbled into nothing but weed weed
you know i'm i'm a scary ass [ __ ] when
it comes to that [ __ ] you wouldn't do
mushrooms
it's from the earth i know i know people
always tell me that
um maybe but [ __ ] i don't have no desire
to or anything like that some people
just like oh it'll make you get through
your day better or maybe it'll make you
look at things a little differently and
i'm like
[ __ ] i right now i like it
yeah you know what i'm saying what about
you denmark i've done i've done shrooms
twice and i have one great experience
and i've had
one not so good experience so i'm uh i'm
like i'm
what was what happened with the not so
good experience well i just had a
i had to just a piece of chocolate i
didn't know how much it was
oh and then uh i just was watching a
movie and it felt like the person in the
movie oh tell them the person though
samuel l jackson was yelling at me
and it tripped me out man big time and
now i was i was in philadelphia
and it was winter and you're in a row
you're in a row home in there so you
can't really get out of nowhere
and that's the first time in uh yeah
that you know homies had to sit me down
you have to relax give me some water
tell me it's all in my head
type [ __ ] and then i was like i'm not
gonna judge it off of that experience
because uh so samuel jackson was like
coming out the tv on you i ain't
[ __ ] with something
one more time
yeah black snake moan i don't know man
he's got something
i can imagine we're way more intense if
you're on trump but i realized though
that you got to be able to be around a
situation where you can move freely and
it's good to
you know do it in like outside in nature
and [ __ ] like that and really enjoy the
full
spectrum of the situation so i went back
and redid the experiences
and it was better yeah it was way better
man i'm like but it's still
i realize you gotta be able to
like you know people who like could have
control over a lot of [ __ ]
probably not gonna like psychedelics in
my opinion because
you don't got no [ __ ] control over
that you know your mind start going
where it's going and
you gotta go with it hit the button and
just go panic you'll get a bad trip or
some [ __ ] like that and that's what
that's what always made me like i feel
like i'd be one of them [ __ ] that'll
start panicking
like and i don't want to take no
[ __ ] chances so i don't do [ __ ]
have you ever had a bad like edible
experience
i had i actually had like a bad like
bung rip experience
like oh wow yeah like i had too much
just trying to hit one of them
big ass bongs trying to just be the
biggest
donor i can be at the time and i must
have cleared it i'm dizzy right
yeah i must have cleared that [ __ ] and
you know i i just you know this was back
in the front volume days like hopson and
swizz was wearing those contacts
and that [ __ ] was just too much for
me and then i remember hopsin took one
of the contacts out it was like
[ __ ] with you i look like a devil or
some [ __ ] and i was like
oh [ __ ] hell no i need to go to sleep
and wake up and start over again like i
tried the highest you ever been it was
the highest that i ever been
where am i what about you denmark what's
the highest you ever highest i ever been
was
was last uh november in europe
uh exhibit always like
he likes to put a p a block of hash and
cut a snickers bar open and put the
block of hash in there and then
close it up and eat it eat it oh [ __ ]
and so for all these years of traveling
with him
i never i never uh i never tried it
and so we were all a shout out problem
he was out there we was all out there
and i said i said [ __ ] it you know this
this time i'm about to do it
and so i took a piece of the snickers
and i ate it and
uh i got back to my hotel room and i
started to feel my body
i started to feel myself like lift above
my body
that's what happened to me and uh you
know and then i just i just laid there
and just let it
let it happen eventually fall asleep but
i i was on some next level
uh yeah man put that put that hashtag
that snickers to eat it
exhibit eats that normally well i'm
saying like on a day off
like let's say we do six seven she's in
the road and it's a day off and he's
like he's like [ __ ] you know
hey i'm about to make the snickers with
the hash and who wants a piece
typically i i would always be like nah
i'm cool you know
did you feel like you had superpowers at
all when you had the edible like that
cause like i had an edible once and uh
it was a really rough night for me it
was a ritz and yellow of concert
and i felt like i could hear everybody
talking in the concert
i could like hone in and like
there was like two thousand people in
this event you're not maybe maybe like
one conversation i'd be on the other
side of the venue and i like look at in
the middle of a concert just look at
somebody on the other side of the
building
and hear exactly what they're saying oh
yeah you was tripping
i don't know if i was tripping though
i felt like i was like yo i couldn't
move my legs though
i remember when i had the hash [ __ ]
like i was like [ __ ] it i feel weird i'm
at throw on like
some youtube and watch like a little
movie or whatever and slowly
but surely the words stopped i stopped
being able to
understand what was being said in the
movie
right it sounded like [ __ ] just started
like what am i even watching like just
cut it off edibles are dangerous because
you can't like
eat to get it to go away you know you
gotta like just let the high pass
there's no other choice yeah [ __ ] it you
can't lie i tried to get in the shower
and wash that [ __ ] off i had to look at
myself in the mirror and everything i
was just like
off a bong hit though off a bunk head
bro you
are you're not a big dabber i imagine i
became a big dabber this was before
dabs was dabs you know wasn't dabbing
yet when i did this
uh and this was actually in minneapolis
i had first got wit
shout out to prince with the funk volume
[ __ ] and it was like my first time
going out there
and like damn kind of had me running
around watching what hopson was
doing you know as far as meet and greets
skating
right listen you're gonna play skate
with fans dizzy you don't know how to
skate
figure out how to skate you're just
gonna go show up at a fan's house and
play them in skates and facts bro
but i remember i i just started making
my little fans you know what i'm saying
and
i went to go smoke with one of my fans
and filled the bong up and tried to hit
that big ass bong and was [ __ ] up
whole world tilted sideway
jesus i don't like being that high